voici mareva galanter
je parle moi j'ai également on à michèle
cotta
je demande à michel costes k qui dirige
france 2 une prime de risque je ne peux
pas faire cette émission je ne peux plus
faire cette émission que tu es comment
les boys alors les mais elle est
franchement thierry fontaine vient
relativiser je sais michel m'ont même
pas on regarde bon croit la commande a
pu se passer de vous pendant quatre
semaines cinq semaines j'ai pensé à vous
en tout cas je sais on a beaucoup parlé
de vous ici aussi touchés elle est déjà
touché alors que nous on brasse pas rien
pas bonjour rien du tout et n'importe
quoi la spéciale
si je me mets embrasser tout le monde ça
va prendre du temps les cadors ils vont
pas savoir où aller car leur cheminement
sur les terrains ils savent où aller
d'accord pour moi j'aime bien normal
j'aimerais voir
ouah via super bon parfois perdre en
plus haletant areva après votre passage
dans l'émission mais c'était impossible
pour vous de revenir parce que vous avez
été à peine on est ravis d'ailleurs tu
n'as fait kidnapper par une chaîne de
télévision
oui et alors ça c'est terminé comment
vous avez un programme cette chaîne ça
s'est terminé
ça c'est pas encore terminée parce que
ça n'a pas commencé mais je présenterai
les m6 howard 17 novembre en direct du
zénith de lille donc vous regardez
ouailles et pluvieux
c'est la solution irak à l'iftar les
senteurs chantier c'est tous les succès
de l'an 2000
alerté par mareva galanter bonjour je
suis même plus probable
c'est bon c'est bon on arrête c'est bon
mari bon je suis excité ça va ça suffit
maintenant lassés du harcèlement sexuel
mais alors mareva non seulement vous ai
présenté les six award sur m6 mais vous
allez présent joué dans julie lescaut
oui j'ai tourné un épisode djl voit la
ville cette émission c'est incroyable
tous non pas de celle que d'un seul non
seulement c'est vachement mais regardez
et en plus dans les personnes qu'il faut
et voilà après on nous appelle on guide
indûment bien chez agoria julie lescaut
nestor burma c'est vrai aussi en étant
normalement c'est vrai oui et un long
métrage avec eric assous aussi exact et
voilà et nous on nous a proposé les
brigades du tigre
et puis évidemment le fixe et mareva
galanter attise les jalousies
comme d'habitude et j'ai vu dans vsd
cette semaine une phrase de sophie
thalmann
otis france me manque et disait j'ai
refusé a visé sophie thalmann j'ai
refusé les propositions de tf1 vous
comprenez moi faire cinq minutes de
prompteur entre des tunnels d'image ça
ne m'intéresse pas mais je sais que
mareva va s'y coller c'est pas très
sympa ça
ouais voilà tout simplement et de
l'alcool
plein de trucs il n'a jamais été
question que je présente une émission de
sport famille est donc je ne sais pas
c'est des mauvaises et arrêter tous
trahis a dit hey ça cartonne entre les
nice entre les gares de tellement sympa
tout les avions puissent aller très
gentil
alors que nous les mister univers nous
allons les savoirs les potes on les
collègues mareva vous aurez des
nouvelles de vie mme dardy autres miss
france j'ai des nouvelles de linda oui
elle va bien bon elle s'est laissé
pousser les cheveux l'annoncé bien c'est
des extensions non je pense qu'on peut
se faire pousser les cheveux oui bien
sûr mais il faut en avoir pour coller
les nouveaux que les élans powell voir
au moins ils font des extensions sa
parole est à l'aise devant
là